what treatment do they give you right
now for coverage i'm not talking about a
vaccine yeah which people obviously
should make that decision between them
and their prescribing physician of
course everyone should have the right
and decision to
control their own body and what they put
in their own body
what treatment though if you already
have covet if you go to the hospital now
they say go home and take tylenol come
back in and they toss you on a
ventilator in other words let's say
ivermectin were used which it has been
in some other countries we cannot argue
whether it's been used effectively or
not because that's not allowed on
youtube however i think we could say joe
rogan did effectively use it though or
at least in his opinion along with the
monoclonal yeah
and the vital antibodies yes yeah but
three days later he tested negative but
the point is i say as an alternative
treatment
let's say you used ivermectin let's say
you use hydroxychloroquine let's say you
used whatever it could be vitamin c
cashton garud take your pick
it would be in lieu of what treatment
given to you at the hospital
none